you don't fix racism with more racism
which by definition excludes people
based on the intrinsic characteristic of
race question of the day your opinions
on affirmative action we have a
changement mind coming up so not only
that but how do you feel it's been
presented in the media also do you think
that I won't be here if I rebut this
video from Vox on affirmative action let
me set this up so you know where we're
going there's a reason this debate makes
you want to cry and it's not just
because it's about race it's because we
suck at talking about race-based
affirmative action mm-hmm well you made
it large okay action I told you that
knocks what an admission you mean you
mean to demean the entire American
population by labeling them as races
understood sorry carry on good SAT score
+10 class president +8 good
you play the bassoon Plus 15 people must
obtain read that these factors are a
good way to decide who should get a seat
yes there's one factor where Americans
disagree race okay first up there's a
reason that I picked this video from box
because it is either the most
misinformed or deliberately selectively
misleading in some of the statistics
that they present I'll get to that in a
second one thing did you notice really
quickly they just talked about SAT
scores playing the bassoon everything
mentioned there with the exception of
luck with the exception of race is
performative playing the bassoon that's
an action getting a good SAT score
that's an action right being black or
Asian not an action by the way this is
important because everyone knows about
some of the new guidelines that have
come out publicly with the purge these
are the same standards used by leftists
for social media including by the way
guidelines for hate speech they claim
that it's wrong and discriminatory to
insult people based on intrinsic
characteristics like race gender etc etc
but affirmative action wants to use
these exact same traits as the exclusive
and only qualifiers for education which
in and of itself education should be
performative irony it hurts
Becky was rejected twice by the UC Davis
Medical School so he filed a lawsuit
back then the school reserves 16 of the
hundred seats the last word Becky
belongs to a wasp remember her
discrimination here it was a quota
battles have been he had higher academic
scores than several minority students
who were accepted and in 1978 in order a
civilian court sided with pakhi the
court at the school couldn't use quotas
to racially balanced the student body
and that they couldn't consider race to
remedy past racial discrimination
the reasoning justice Lewis Powell wrote
that societal discrimination is not a
valid reason for considering race yeah
yeah you don't fix racism with more
racism which machen is by definition it
excludes people based on the intrinsic
characteristic of race that's a good
thing is it just the man who met higher
performance standards became a doctor
any patients out there awaiting a valve
transplant want to argue this is a bad
thing this doesn't exist in a vacuum
by the way when we're talking about
affirmative action let's before we move
on to the micro and the statistics which
i think are very important the macro
here education is meant to prepare you
for the world it's not about the college
experience we've turned it into four
years of glorified alcoholism these
people are going to be building our
planes and separating conjoined twins I
don't care how many vowels are in your
last name we want you to be good at what
we want you to give good at what you do
that should be the primary goal of
education and this is interesting
because um Becky was an older student by
the way in his early 30s who is turned
down by many institutions because he was
considered too old college students aged
30 to 35 only make up about 16% of the
college population okay that'll be
important later on to come back to as we
go through percentages because you know
this is a whole percentage game again I
want the best person as my doctor okay
next clip here's the rest of Justice
Powell's decision the only estate
interest that fairly may be viewed as
compelling on this record
is the interest of a university in a
diverse student body so university
administrators could no longer use
affirmative action to address past
discrimination but they could use it to
create a diverse student body and to be
fair diversity is beneficial to everyone
for example research shows that it
exposes like a gross generalization
thinking which helps them better solve
problems I just listen I'm not arguing
right now that they were certainly not
saying that diversity is bad just read a
sake of diversity that's what I'm saying
there the one thing that diversity is
good for the sake of diversity but
diversity is good for everyone right
what about battered women's shelters
yeah yes even their ham-fisted men and
their I want men with Fifth's like lunch
boxes walking through the door well you
not always know what about conservatives
on YouTube how about that that sounds
terrible bleep and mute Gerald's knife
blow-up doll that's all I want to hear
if I see a blow-up doll so help me God
so again if the goal is to create
diversity among the student body
wouldn't including older senior citizens
students also be of interest and say
make up a smaller portion of the student
body then black students to begin with I
don't seem like back if you want to
create diversity that would be an
important one also something important
did you notice a source that Vox
provides there it's actually an article
from the pro affirmative action
nonprofit it's called the Century
Foundation which cites they said amicus
briefs from the UT Austin Supreme Court
case ok this research though that they
talk about with diversity it's only
vague statements from Vox and there's no
hard data so for example one of the
briefs it states a diverse student
population creates a richer learning
environment because students learn most
from those who have very different life
experience from theirs ok sounds right
another says college students who
experience positive interactions with
students from different racial
backgrounds results in more open minds
and engaging classroom conversations ok
doesn't necessarily sound like hard yet
let's look at some of the hard data and
this stay with me here because I Ernie's
ok
we know that some kinds of diversity can
a negatively impact student performance
now don't before you before you start on
at the David Duke accusation no that's
not where I'm going
studies are credit students in single
gender schools for example have better
academic outcomes when these schools
have been made co-ed for example
all-boys schools and all-girls schools
academic performance dropped some reach
some research supports of course that
racial gender diversity is good when
applied to academic performance but it
really this relates to kindergarten
through 12 right and by the way it
mostly applies to teachers kill more so
than students if you look at the data
because people are learning from their
teachers and may learn new life
experiences for the same reason that you
don't want your children to get the sex
talk from the kid in the schoolyard
regardless of race or gender you rather
do it yourself for dat kids gross by the
way notice something's anyone noticed
something else here this is really this
is what's so disturbing to me do you
notice something about the argument that
have been made by fox thus far hmm all
of these they could be used to create
racially segregated schools when you're
talking about this when you look through
everything through the prism of lenss
and you just look at it through
diversity of race and you're not talking
about intellectual diversity look at you
go away hold on a second there's better
academic performance and boys only
schools are in girls only schools these
same arguments could be used by racists
or white supremacists themselves because
you see things exclusively through the
prism of race rather than performative
actions this is important let's look
specifically at the type of diversity in
affirmative action has created as a
ripple effect on campus even the left in
publication the atlantic k is covered in
depth how many students brought in by
affirmative action if that bad quote bad
I want to make sure you know I'm not
mystery bad quote bad from Atlantic
Macca demmick experience is because they
were mismatched against students who
have better academic qualifications now
what am I talking about here I'm not
saying that bad experiences because
they're Asians are there are black kids
what I'm saying is people who got into
schools who were not qualified for those
positions ended up having bad
experiences because of seeing the
results through the lens of racial
diversity exclusively black students
interested in pursuing a doctorate
they're twice as likely to be derailed
from the path they
to school where they are mismatched 50%
of black college students right now
ranked in the bottom 20% of their
classes bottom 10% of law school do you
know four times since affirmative actor
is four times more likely to fail the
bar now you could argue this because
every single professor is racist in
higher education and the bar exam is
systemically racist I would think the
more the more straight intellectual line
to draw would be someone who's admitted
on the basis exclusively of race with
lower academic performance standards
might leave school with lower academic
performance standards that's why they
fill the bar here's the definitive and
we're going to continue undergirding
this if diversity is about filling a
quota fine just say that but if it's
about helping minority students it has
definitively demonstrably hurt minority
students not help them okay
next clip Harvard assigns each applicant
something called a personal score to
measure subjective things like kindness
courage and leadership organ looks like
a pan-asian applicants are scored lower
than white applicants meanwhile Asians
can be double sampled bills moments or
higher than white applicants actually
who she is Asians have better academic
profiles Harvard is using this personal
score to balance out the number of
Asians they get which is but in this
chart you can see that the share of
Asian students varies a lot from year to
year most misleading ground the holding
Harvard had a quota you'd expect that
share to stay the same by notice how Fox
they sort of create a gimmick with this
chart they try to make it look like this
is important this is why I think this is
deliberately misleading because you
would have to seek out a way to
manipulate a statistic that is far less
straightforward than the statistic that
matters I think correctly wrong everyone
in this room and if you're watching
comment below
okay so pause it respond so we can get a
genuine answer I would think the
statistic if we're talking about the
percentage of the student population
made up by minorities that you most care
about is what percentage of the student
population is made up of minorities
correct Jeff okay that's not what that
graph shows okay if you read
on the chart it is the change in share
of admitted students who are Asian they
aren't looking at the percentage of
Asians by year which remains remarkably
stable just take a look Harvard
currently has around 25% of Asian
students that percentage has been
unbelievably stable over the years
regardless and this is why it's
important regardless of application
numbers from Asian students the chart
that they use just looks at a percentage
of change each year
that's a percentage of a percentage let
me explain if this sounds a little bit
difficult because I don't math is not
any of us here despite my I am NOT a
math agent you're a lawyer yes and that
is not intrinsic it is because of your
education and I respect you for it yes
you're wrong it has nothing to do with
you being slight and relatively hairless
except where it matters
beautiful quaff so let me explain the
Asians for example only make up 25% of a
student body okay a 10% change is only a
2.5 percent change of the student body
so to use this bring up the overlay here
let's use their high number of 17% on
that chart most people I think watching
this assume that means oh there's a 17%
there's now 17% more Asian students on
campus know to signify that variance it
would really only require a 4% change in
the overall student body from 24% say to
28% you understand that a 17% change
from 24 to 28 and most of those years
have like a 3% change that surrounding
error it's really hard to have negative
Asians in your student body pretty
unclear
that's what how's a negative 7 yeah I
mean so again the more important number
I think too that we should be focusing
it's not only percentage-wise I don't
really actually care about percentage of
the campus population I care about
people getting in who are qualified and
intellectual diversity so let's look at
the number hard data the the SAT scores
required to get into Harvard these are
numbers we can look at at Harvard and we
know this because of the recent case so
V we don't know this at all schools it
happens behind closed doors we're
fortunate enough that we know these
numbers from Harvard okay we have
numbers on African Americans Native
Americans Hispanics okay they were
accepted was SAT scores
on average of 1,100 white students
needed a score of at least 1310 Asian
Americans needed 1350 for women and 1380
for men now this is important because
everyone looks at this and goes well on
a second Asians have been
over-represented on college campus if
you see everything through the prism of
lens which I believe is inherently
racist I know I'm not supposed to say it
but I believe if you only see people as
Asian black white and the statistical
realities you're a racist
that's just opinion you know
merriam-webster keep in mind
everyone goes agents are
over-represented so that's a good thing
well have you done the math an Asian
woman requires a higher SAT score to get
into Harvard than a white male a white
male the pumpkin spice latte of students
speaking of notification bell if you're
subscribed because the subscriptions
don't always work no by the way we just
upload videos every day at 8 p.m.
Eastern join my club lot of credit calm
/ mug Club right now we are not
monetized this is what sustains us to
talk about these issues point well made
half asian lawyer bill Richman next clip
at very selective private colleges
Asians make up the second biggest group
because Asians work harder or care more
about education we're all most of our
families weren't sent to policies like
Jim Crow and redlining that engineered
yes exactly away from the US eventually
allowed Asians into the country and we
arrived in large numbers but US
immigration policies selected for
certain slots the saying that's where
the mistake where we can strive u.s.
immigrants with college degrees and
Asians are among the most educated by
the way just because my half Asian
lawyer bill always gets a little nervous
if I get into hot water when discussing
racial issues do you have any idea how
not I would be crucified and then put on
a rail so they could run me out if they
said the majority of students are white
and I said quote
[Laughter]
I'm telling you the other half of me
would have wooed for the white people no
half as liberal Richmond was nervous
about this no the reason what they say
it's not because Asians work harder yet
it's because asian-americans are more
capable in an education environment
because they work harder data reflects
that they study longer hours on average
and more importance is placed on
education you even told me you didn't
get weekends and penological days were
just days of horrible abuse yeah I don't
know what a weekend is yeah they claim
here's another just irony alert okay and
I want to be I'm hurting myself for you
both in watching these videos and in
doing this that hurts that's not
pleasant Lee do Wow so I you know I can
spare the brain cells because apparently
whiteness that's the corner of the chart
privilege they started importing us
amass irish-italian
box they claim here that Asians don't do
well in higher education not because
they're harder workers or because they
care about education rather it's because
many Asian immigrants came after
anti-asian racism and they didn't
experience the same racism that other
minorities did but hold on a second why
do Asians hugely outperform white
students on average can we know the huge
irony here that Fox's arguing Asians
have succeeded because they haven't
faced discrimination while talking about
how one of the top universities in the
nation has been shown to systemically
rate Asian personalities poorly and
exclude them because of bills mom it's
true Asians have have done well not
because of discrimination what's going
on Harvard discrimination hmm I just
want to make sure that mr. eyes my
thoughts no you haven't Fox nor your
sources that would be nice what a
hyperlink it maybe now in that despite
this Asians they still outperform whites
supposedly the most privileged race ever
but box still doesn't give them any
credit for it I want to be clear like
this is a statistical reality Asian
students tend to perform better not
because of skin tint but because of
studying art better than white students
on average don't get credit for finally
Vox is presented with this example
an institution okay of racism to go back
to the topic concrete data they won't
recognize it because it doesn't fit with
their vision of discrimination which I
don't frankly I don't understand what
the Vox vision of determination is when
someone says doesn't make sense
we want a policy that discriminates
against an entire race of people
exclusively because of their race and I
said what is that it's not
discrimination why then I don't know
what it is what is it I don't know what
to call it
it's a Vox video that's what everyone is
guaranteed equal protection of the laws
but looking at her history helps us
understand why that's misleading the
Equal Protection Clause was created to
protect the rights of black people after
the Civil War and the Supreme Court has
cited it good things like brown v board
and Loving v Virginia cases that made
American society more inclusive lest we
get in trouble can we all agree that
protecting rights for black Americans
posed a good thing no one hears our for
example yes for excluding blacks from
civil rights as Vox would be excluding
Asians from universities why make sure
right just we would not sink to their
level
so Vox argues that because Brown versus
Virginia that it made America more
inclusive that apparently should also
act as a point in favor of affirmative
action it's the opposite of that I would
argue let me make my case in those cases
we were just ensuring equal treatment
under the law schools were no longer
segregated and interracial marriage was
no longer illegal those cases determined
that you could not exclude people from
basic rights or being allowed entrance
based on performative metrics through
excluding them racially I just want to
be clear that we're seeing the opposite
it's a little bit different it's like we
on say that ten percent of population
has to be interracially married sorry
we've reached the ninety four regular
couples you can't do it right understand
coronel rosario Dawson is very
attractive but build our quota would you
be okay with 2019 Cyndi Lauper the
answer is always no next Supreme Court
says that schools
use the history of racial discrimination
as a defense for considering race
the only thing schools can say is
diversity is good for everyone and soon
if this harbor case makes it in front of
the court colleges might not even be
able to make that argument which means a
place like Harvard the training ground
for America's elite watch this we're
about in the 1 & 4 students are
currently black or Hispanic would go
back to looking the way it did two
generations ago and conservatives will
finally get what colorblind problems now
they're all white one other violence
final graphic is just an 8-bit version
of the Sandlot finale to the 60s and we
never saw him again we're gonna save
everyone to white like finally
Republicans slash David Duke and
Klansmen will get the universities they
always what did you notice that when
they said that it would it would only
cause Hispanics and african-americans to
go away and then it would leave it
somehow all white right and again here
we have the left vision of
discrimination yeah we're agents never
get discriminated again somehow they are
better than everyone and definitely
should just be put down and and if and
if you get rid of these policies let's
be real my cousins and I are gonna take
over Harvard just because you picked the
graphics from NES is motocross I married
Mark Zuckerberg we left school it was a
great game it was a great game they
decided that they were going to eat like
I mean also okay I don't know if we can
say first off you have your NBC
Universal Comcast one of the biggest
multimedia conglomerates in the world
can you can you do some graphics and get
my hire a voice-over artist I can we
look at one point please have no more
getting free like you have the money
they're spending all the money on this I
love not all your animations have to
look like pong by the way if we went
back to how things look like performer
affirmative action this is this is
something that's really important Kay
hold your old your nose here comes the
cold water we'd actually have more black
student
minorities at top colleges with
affirmative action post implementation
of affirmative action we now have less
blacks and hispanics at the top
universities than 35 years ago that's
the elephant in the room that Vox
refuses to mention I guess in this case
the tiger and they're stupid they're too
concerned with the Tigers in the world
this even did you just make that up
where did you get that source from New
York Times
now the hyper Snopes fat checks New York
Times in the video no New York Times is
gonna fact-check New York Times little
fact has three Pinocchio's for fake news
New York Times because someone on
YouTube is just putting themself in the
pretzels like Yogi Bear we don't do
research we just recognize how racist
this is Fox assumes that if universities
only considered SAT scores in academic
data you know things that matter for
schools that blacks and other minorities
would never be able to perform well
enough to get in hmm the data shows that
they were doing better without
affirmative action and of course the
success of Asians because a contrary to
it Vox Asians have faced systemic
discrimination we have a changed my mind
coming on this issue and by the way one
where I discussed this issue of that
will surprise you with a black professor
of hip-hop from both Princeton and UT
Austin so it's a pretty diverse change
remind a little bit more personal than
most I think they'll be surprised how it
ends up but here's here's a couple of
things this is why this personally
bothers me hopefully the data has helped
you all of those sources are available
you can find them yourself okay you have
to believe two things to support
affirmative action okay
number one you have to leave that it's
the moral thing to do that more racism
corrects previous racism number two you
have to believe that it works okay so
let's assume that you believe number one
okay you believe that racism fix fix is
racing and I'm not saying reverse racism
just racism it's racism to exclude Asian
even though they deserve to be there
just because they're Asian it's not
reverse racism just racism let's assume
that you believe racism which is what
affirmative action is is the moral thing
to do okay but point number two you
would have to believe it's the moral
thing to do because it works
statistically it doesn't even if you
believe it's morally imperative
it hurts minorities more it is
undeniable at what point do we say hold
on a second rather than seeing
everything through the prism of race the
lens of race which has hurt minorities
we should maybe do the right thing at
this point which is not be colorblind
but not judge people exclusively based
on intrinsic characteristics and you
know why this matters a whole lot to me
I know people say you shouldn't have an
opinion because you're a white guy just
like I can't have an opinion on a woman
shopping up a baby and sucking it down a
tube leaving it in a dumpster because I
have a penis I understand the rules
but let me tell you why this matters to
me because this kind of false
information borderline propaganda will
create an entire generation of racists
to come that is what bothers me is I
don't want to see a racist future
America and guess what if you have
another little half asian Bill Richmond
who gets a 1350 SAT score in five years
from now and he sees somebody who was
far less qualified was getting an 1,100
SAT score and that person is solely
admitted because of race this guy isn't
going to take into account all of the
racial and justices of the past he's
going to understand that he has been
screwed and gotten a wrong deal like a
raw deal sorry No Deal that's the raw
deal from Arnold that was a slogan he
got a raw deal no one gives Arnold a raw
deal his only one that trailer was No
Deal so No Deal what I am saying is that
boy or that girl or that asian girl will
not take into account the entire
historical context of any of all racial
discriminations that have been done by
the way in other continents and the
United States they will understand that
they are getting a raw deal and guess
what do you know do you know how racists
recruit for their clans for their gangs
they convinced people that they are
getting a raw deal wrongfully so by the
way for a long time most of the time
based on race they convinced a lot of
young white people that they are getting
a raw deal because of their whiteness
and guess what when you tell people
young people you're not going to be
allowed in because of your whiteness or
because of your Asian miss you are
justifying the recruitment
patterns that racists use themselves
there is no difference I care about
affirmative action because it is racist
and I don't want to race this country
No Deal hey this video subscribe or hit
the notification bell because that lets
your mobile device do people still say
cell I don't think they say but no one
says LTE we should say cellular but we
don't say LTE but then what was there is
roaming do we still have roaming I think
we still have roaming if you're watching
this on mobile I've wasted a ton of your
and you're likely driving you're
probably dead everybody's looking back
now and the road is just there are some
lights and sirens going off maybe
there's like a pair of slacks in your
the grille of your car next to the
Rudolph nose that you put in for some
holiday festivity only now it's covered
in someone else's blood so hit the
notification bell join mug Club it
lighter with credit calm slash mug club
because that's how we support this we
don't actually make any money off of
youtube and we do a full dailies like
80% more content and you know what I
hope that your blood type is o-negative